the more I try to chase them and I want
to make the money I want to make the
money you can see these people they're
so desperate they don't make money you
don't make money if your life stinks is
your fault we take responsibility for
own action our money is not that
important money doesn't buy happiness oh
my goodness let me think let me think
you're broke lead motivation watch a top
ten with belief nation what's that
believe nation it seven I believe in you
and this channel is designed to be a
part of your daily success routine so
let's get your motivation to attend and
get you believing in you grab a snack
and chew on today's lessons from a man
who came to Canada at age fourteen
knowing zero English then started 13
different businesses and failed at all
of them to becoming the king of high
ticket sales and a highly successful
entrepreneur and consultant he's day in
lock and here's my take on his top 50
rules for success also if you want to
know what day in lock and other
successful entrepreneurs have to say
about building unstoppable confidence
check out my 250 for confident series
where every day for the next 254 days I
will send you a morning video for free
to help you build your confidence too
late to join is in the description below
after you practice Marshall you develop
this natural self confidence not
cockiness but you develop this natural
self-confidence
okay let's kick it off with rule number
one learn more when the first business
pilot that I had it was like a basically
he was my neighbor at a time I was
trying to build my little business and
he sold me on the concept oh you need a
website and I pay him some money a long
story short he's basically scared me out
of like hundred fifty thousand dollars I
lost all my mom's money all the savings
and I didn't know anything about into
the marketing and then right after that
because that experience was so traumatic
for me from then on everything I do I
said I want to learn in a hundred
percent so I went and at a time internet
marketing I bought the corey rudl course
and remember the insider secrets to
mocking the internet right that the two
big binders like six hundred pages I
went through in two days Wow and from
then on I was just like reading every I
forget about like reading a book a month
I was reading a book every two three
days so that experience change how I
operate and that that's how it evolved
this hunger to learn yeah as much as I
could so I would feel I don't think it's
a healthy thing is when I went to Tony's
event unleash the power within yeah I
don't know there's there's a healthy
thing but I always have this feeling of
no I need it no more right I need to
know more rule number two add value
first I was knocking on door and no one
like I was not gonna hey do you want me
to Milano no we don't need that we're
only a - yeah at a time I had my mom had
a friend my aunt she had a printing
business right like you know printing
business card and flyers and all that so
I went to my aunt I said why don't you
know you print a bunch of flyers
I would help to distribute in the in the
neighborhood like printing service but
yeah they're two sides are flying right
between 5,000 of these I'll run around
I'll distribute it on the other side can
I put my sub money yeah my lawn-mowing
since I go what the heck yeah it's all
been always very entrepreneurial yeah
you know how to you know be resourceful
in the city yeah yeah yeah cuz a lot of
people wouldn't have even tried that
because they'll say well I don't have
the money for lawn mow or I don't have
any of that so it stopped them right
yeah it's a good proof right there that
it's not about what you have it's about
what you
do with what you have hundred percent
were including that even at a young age
it's never lack of resources I think
it's a lack of resource fulness and and
I was just resourceful I had no money so
I had time I can put in effort and I
distribute all five of your flyers I ran
home and I was just waiting for the
phone I thought I'm gonna get rich yeah
oh my god five five thousand people I'm
like I'm gonna to get a hundred phone
call or I'm gonna pull my time I'm still
going to school I thought I'm gonna make
like House Isabella's right right one
hour
no call mmm one day no call three days
not a single one now let's check the
flush get I put at the wrong number
right knows what the right number right
not a single phone call from the flyer
all right and and I learned okay there's
something that you know you can have a
great product a great service but if you
don't know how to get it out there do
marketing in and get people to pay
attention no one's gonna buy from you so
I came an idea I thought to myself and
this affected my philosophy for the rest
of my life man is a philosophy so I
thought think back
the very first client I had could pay me
20 bucks
what did I do I mow the lawn first
before asking anything in return that's
how I got that first $20 right right
yeah I thought let me do that again so I
ran around the neighborhood and I found
one of the most probably one of the
higher-end expensive homes in the
neighborhood and I saw the lawn was like
up to this high like high and I just
found it fun a day and it just mowed and
I think that's illegal to do that I'm
not an advocate of that but I did that
so you didn't even knock on their door
you know I know the whole lawn right I
did the whole thing right and I finish
whole thing and I set at the front door
waiting for the homeowner to come back
okay she is funny it's a housewife she
came back and she couldn't she couldn't
recognize her lawn this is this not
right yeah she drove by and then she
drove back and she pulled what the hell
is going on right right and she's like
who are you like I said you know I said
just a kid I'm trying to make you know
make some money
I provide these services a fly oh this
is awesome you know my husband travels
all the time
he never is never home I can't do this
stuff thank you so much you make my lawn
looks like she gave me $100 Wow
okay two dollars right and that affected
me for the rest of my life so my
business philosophy until this very day
if you say one of my motive for for
business add value first before you ask
anything return that's how I always
approach you know how most business
people they approach somebody yeah they
want to sell them some right right all
they want to hey man you do something
for me or like you know on social media
people come to me all the time or they
feel like just because I'm successful
that I'm obligated to help them right
you can show easily or so easily we'll
just give them yeah chase you got be
gonna earn it so my philosophy is any
interaction with people how can I add
value to what you do it's always my most
favorite questions this what is the most
important project you're working on that
can add value to rule number three
improve yourself many years ago when I
first met my mentor and I was telling
him about all these businesses that I've
started I said hey you know Alan I mean
I started all these businesses and then
somehow I don't know man I'm not I'm not
making enough money I'm struggling I
don't know why my my my customers
they're like chief they're very
difficult to deal with and I mean I
don't know the economy and it's kind of
sucks and I think I paid too much in
taxes I mean I was rambling on and
complaining and bitching of all these
things and he said stop I said what is
it stop
is that what do you mean is it stop is
it it's very simple dance let me teach
you something it said if your business
sucks is because as a business person
you suck I said what no us no I work
hard I said I always very defensive' I
was like I learned and I try to try to
do my best and try to serve my customers
said no you suck as a business person
he said if if you've got sales problem
it means you suck as a sales person if
you've got employee problem it means it
sucks at you you are managing the
business leader
it's very very simple sir remember this
your business is always a reflection of
you your business always reflection of
you nothing more so if you think about
it why most businesses fail I think why
most business fail it because the reason
the intent most people they stopped the
businesses for the wrong reason they
start the business because they want to
get out of a job
they started business because they want
to they want to make money of course
nothing wrong with that they start a
business because they think maybe
there's an opportunity it sounds like
it's easy where the big money is not it
started for the wrong reason versus they
see a need in the marketplace this skill
there's a this expertise is some valid
it could bring to that particular
industry right there's something that
you could bring to think about it it's
like if thinking of starting a business
like flying a plane and you can't just
say well I'm passionate I have a great
idea let me fly that plane well you have
your food I've you fly plane before no
do you know what if I play no do you
know where you're going no but looks
like fun let me go on a plane one our
chances of you crashing very high and
that's why statistics shows 90% of small
business fail in the first five years
even the ones who survive after five
years most of them don't don't pass the
million dollar mark they're just kind of
surviving and that's why people go into
business for the wrong reason and they
go into business without the proper
training without the skills I could tell
you when I had all those failures when I
started all these crazy businesses and
why they fail it's not because the
vehicle is because of me as a business
person that I didn't have the business
acumen I didn't have the business
experience I didn't know anything about
leadership marketing sales negotiation
raising capital any
skills I have today so everything I did
it didn't work because I was a lousy
business person I sucked as a business
person but I learned from my mistakes
and that's the good thing about business
you can suck many many many years when
you get better you learn from it you get
you suck less and when you practice and
you dust yourself all you learn for
mistakes
you suck even little mess until whether
you wake up you say you know what I
don't suck no more and one win in
business can make up a lot of losses one
win can make up for all your losses
rule number four set wealth triggers so
you notice I have a lot of wealth
triggers in my office so it's not this
decorative item everything means
something to write so I have like you
know the LK that's thought that
represents personal branding yeah so I
can think about that like leadership
energy and sure wisdom so everything is
dead in my office I wanted to call them
wealth triggers
yeah you should this [ __ ] create certain
type of feeling environment for me right
I was believing environments more
powerful yeah your your real power right
I want it sturdy so I have meetings
you're awesome I'm that's all sir
every week all those yeah yeah and then
have the Chinese kind of Friday in there
I'll see if I can translate that
basically means a kind of like the outer
wall and battles one before they were
fought right and and your decisions
affect affect with the the outcome of
the battle even your like thousand miles
away right let's watch me that's cold I
like the strategy I love it rule number
five find mentors I tried most things
like most people I rep this success
books and already she's thinking Grow
Rich and how to win the friends
influence be here right right you know
back and forth many times like all these
books and you know I would get up in the
morning and I would look in the mirror
and say I'm successful and there could
be a great day information information
and and I would I would visualize I say
put me in a vision board I do know I did
all that stuff right here so you know
yes
yes you know all right stuff right so it
was okay I think all those things they
helped but really that the turning point
was when I find my first mentor his name
is Allen Allen Allen and at that time
Allen was he ran one of the the it was
the founder of a ring with the
investment network in Canada which was
at the time one of the largest real
estate investment network in Canada and
how did you find him good question I
want to ask you that because there might
be somebody listening this or watching
this that might be on their 12th or 13th
failure yeah right at that turning point
so it's somebody sitting there and kind
of confused how how did you find your
mentor and what would be your
recommendation oh I'll tell you how I
found my mentor and I'll give then I'll
give them the advice of what where to
find so at a time I was just like an
opportunity junkie okay I know money's
our attendees like free seminars and I
would get on these like mailing lists
right and Alan was running one of the
largest financial seminar companies in
Canada and he was the first one that
brought war but your sake mmm from Rich
Dad Poor Dad robust gunshot before even
the gears like it was famous it was the
first guy so I was getting all these
junk mails direct mail like not not
Instagram Facebook right direct mail
right yeah and I would always always be
fascinated by the way that he would
write these sales letters right and I
would collect them mm-hmm I would
collect him put in a fuel punched him
put him a binder and I would save them
and we'll study them
I just fascinated by the way he
communicates right so the copywriting on
topper idea and he's I remember the name
Alan Jack's right this is name and at
one time was attending a free conference
or seen sitting in the back and I was
watching the speaker Jenna a gentleman
sat down next to me and watching the
speaker was looking at you I was looking
that's like I know there's a name ken
yeah it's just Alan Jack's Wow and I
thought no way yeah
no way and I said are you Alan jacks he
said yes I said are you the one that's
hosting these events inviting these
letters and it's like yes I am what
they're called right that's my internal
dialogue I try to be calm right as I'm a
huge fan
yeah like I I love what you do and he
thought I was referring to the event but
yeah yeah you know we do pretty good
events I said no no no no I study your
letters here as I collect them I tell
them I I collect these letters and he
was shocked because I don't think he's
ever had anyone telling him that all
right young guy 2020 someone 21 years
old my pocket handing out of my copy
right yeah like collecting the junk mail
and I was just faster they said I said I
said mr. Jackson can i buy your lunch
mm-hmm and always remember to reply he
pause he said what the hell I gotta eat
yeah that was the start of a
relationship
Wow and we had lunch we talk for hours
and then I afterwards I asked him to be
my mentor would you turn me down
mm-hmm and I was again not recommending
this I was basically stalking him in his
office why I rented office every day if
we tell you it physically go there I'll
do the office I would say anything I
would pick up the trash anything yeah I
was just demonstrating I want to help
anything yeah I don't care about money I
don't want a salary I don't want
anything and and finally a monthly
that's okay I just need a higher you
just oh this is this is like this is
spotting me so much money he's part of
my staff fine like this young man it's
like crazy right and he did and I worked
for him for almost four year for next to
nothing that was funny story so we would
do a lot to write mail right so we stuff
these envelopes and I will help stop the
envelopes and you know the envelope the
stems and I'm like the liquid envelope
right and I would put the after about
two weeks of that he said Dan you can
actually use water for that Oso Oso
though it's getting poison a licking 500
envelopes like that and put the whole
thing in
but that's how I got started right
that's like how naive I was by what is
hungry rule number six get good habits
we are what we repeatedly do human
beings we are creatures of habits you
notice that you kind of do the same
thing the same routine over over and
again and again and again see become
getting rich is not an act it is a habit
so it is staying poor it's also not an
act it's nothing just happens to you it
is a habit so let me teach you the three
best habits of rich people the very
first habit of rich people and that is
they count their money poor people don't
count their money they get a paycheck
they deposit a paycheck they spend the
money they have no idea what the
expenses are you have no idea how the
money flows you know this poor people
they enjoy OB they have a job and wait
till maybe once a year when they found
out they would tax return is the Texas
that are owning is how much have to pay
they look at the numbers they even look
at the numbers it's just okay all right
that's what how much I need to pay
without a tax return and death yeah look
at it maybe maybe once a year rich
people we don't do that we look at our
numbers regularly we are financially
literate I'm not a numbers person don't
get me wrong ok I'm a concept guy ok I'm
a big-picture thinker I'm a visionary
but I am very very careful and I'm very
aware how my money is flowing habit
number two is they pay themselves first
now you've heard of this before
oh yeah I know I then I've heard of this
this before you got to pay yourself do
you know actually what that means paying
yourself doesn't buy yourself a car it
doesn't mean taking that vacation it
doesn't mean that you know you would you
know you go blow money on entertainment
oh yeah I'm paying money myself
no that's paying everybody else when
you're buying a car you're paying the
automotive motive company when you're
buying a house you are paying the bank
when you are traveling you are paying
the the travel agency you're paying the
hotel you're paying the the flight
company airplane
company ping yourself meaning that you
put your money aside and you invest your
money now I'm not talking about being
frugal you know if you know anything
about me
you know my work I'm not talking about
being frugal and being cheap I'm talking
about taking a piss percentage of your
income and putting that aside pay
yourself first and save it and then you
invest it habit of rich people number
three and that is rich people are
constantly improving their earning
ability because you might be thinking
Danny okay I want to pay myself first
but I'm not making enough money I'm only
making a few dollars in a month i
couldíve I couldn't even afford to pay
my bills how am I gonna pay myself first
first of all you gotta have the habit of
paying yourself first if you're not
paying yourself first even a tiny small
percentage when you're making 30 40 50
60 $100,000 a year I guarantee you when
you're making million two million
dollars a year you're not paying
yourself it is a habit that I'm talking
about and in order to do that in order
to be able to every single year to be
able to pay yourself more and more and
more and put into investments you need
to improve your earning ability you need
to find ways how you can add value to
the marketplace how to add more value to
the marketplace so every single year
your income is going up every year if
you've been you've been working in house
in the real world and you have your own
business and your income kinda stays
flat for the last two three five years
and shame on you it means you're not
learning it means you're not thinking it
means you're not growing every single
year your income you have to strive to
improve that your earning ability and
the rich people we're always constantly
looking for ways to improve our earning
ability but also looking for ways to ant
leverage to apply leverage into what we
do rule number seven don't have
unrealistic expectations and why do you
think so many people fail in spite of
the best efforts you know a lot of
people watching this right now they've
maybe tried different ways of making
money online or building businesses why
do you think is the the main reason why
a lot of people fail I think that two
main reasons the first one is I think
because of the whole internet that they
have people have this unwilling
they see someone like you and say oh
Stefan is doing this it's got a YouTube
channel and he's doing Kindle publishing
and I want to do that you know I maybe
I'll make some videos to what they don't
see is how many years of effort that you
put into it
so most people they listen to a webinar
they watch a video and they say oh this
guy's making whatever how much money
online I could do that and they jump
into it and then they try for three
months and so all this thing doesn't
work yeah right oh I take some into the
next thing
Bitcoin whatever now it's Bitcoin so
hard right oh and then and then they try
that and then try for three month all
that doesn't work they try the next
thing so I think that expectations
unrest expectation lead to lead to
disappointment and failure rule number
eight have a healthy mind and body I saw
a couple comments on YouTube people
asking what dan do you recommend these
like mine stimulating your mind and
hinging drugs the answer is absolutely
not if you follow my work you know I
don't smoke I don't drink and I don't do
drugs I don't even drink coffee right I
drink like honey green tea that's what I
drink and water and maybe from time to
time you know cook zero when I'm
watching a movie or something like that
that's it
no drugs no cigarettes and no alcohol
why is that because you notice a lot of
times even with my own story my father
was actually a very heavy smoker I want
to say he said hey he was an alcoholic
but he drinks quite a bit he enjoys a
glass here and there and I do notice
later on when he had the stroke he had
all the when his health was in it was
declining a lot of those habits
contributed to that if you don't have a
healthy body a healthy mind there's no
way in hell you'll be able to sustain
the stress the the pressure it takes to
be successful so I don't think you need
those things you only need those mind
handing drugs to be successful to have
more clarity and all dish if you want
you enjoy a drink here and there that's
perfectly fine I'm just saying I don't
do it I don't need to have alcohol to
have a good time and when I drink I like
people if hey Dan just a zip of beer
it's okay enjoy they don't taste good to
me quite frankly even they taste like
that but they don't even taste it to me
so I don't enjoy I don't need those
things to have a good time if I have a
good time good company good friends good
conversation I have a good time and I
don't need to get high to do to I get
high on doing what I love I get high on
just life I get high on being the impact
of people rule number nine up your
thermostat alright great ideas alone are
not enough why great ideas along are not
enough to change our lives you see one
of the great mistakes that most people
make is they are tending to change their
body their arch am telling to change the
relationship they are telling to change
the income their finance they are
tending to change something outside of
themselves in searching something that's
inside with themselves some people see
themselves as conservative and unsafe
are they gonna do anything crazy are
they gonna go bungee jumping or
skydiving no unless you drunk or
something like that so you're not gonna
do anything crazy or at nuts
unless you're drunk now you might say
it's the alcohol but really it's just
you finally getting permission to be
yourself the alcohol is just an excuse
if you are playful if you're fun if
you're outrageous you're gonna talk
differently gonna move differently you
know dress differently maybe in a red
suit
and you're gonna do things differently
and there's no right or wrong but most
of us have trapped ourselves in an old
self-image and never really update who
we are today so then when you go and
learn a new skill when you go learn a
new ability a new idea but we're stuck
in this self-image this is who I am and
that's why we never surpass it let me
give you a metaphor this would make
sense for you let's say in this room
that we set the thermostat at 70 degrees
let's say that 70 degrees it's a
metaphor it's a what metaphor for your
comfort zone which is also known as your
self-image your comfort zone and most
people have goals that are larger
they're more than their self-image and
that's why most people don't get to
their goals unless they alter and or
expand their self-image so 70 degrees is
your comfort zone
70 degrees it's your body not your goal
not where you want to be eventually but
what you're comfortable with
70 degrees is your the amount of love
and passion and connection you have in
your personal intimate relationship
again not your goal but you know what
where you live with what you live with
regularly 70 degrees is the amount of
money that you need to make to be
comfortable not your goal what you're
comfortable with let's say the
temperature drops to 65 degrees now what
happens is your brain goes hey hey hey
I'm a 70 degree or not a 65 the heaters
kicked on you feel this a drive and this
dis urge and you want to do something
about it by show of hand how many I've
ever had experienced part of life maybe
your body maybe your income maybe your
relationship where it dropped and you
fell it's not good enough and you fell
this incredible try to do something
about it yeah but without way of and say
oh yeah oh yeah and from there and you
try something and it doesn't work and
you try something else and it doesn't
work and you try something else and it
doesn't work
now after a while nobody wants to be a
disappointment no one no one wants to
feel like a failure in their lives so
what some people do is
they lower the thermostats they lower
their expectations they make their goals
smaller more realistic more reasonable
don't get your hopes up or you'll be
disappointed well you know maybe maybe
not I'm not a 70 70 degree labor hour 65
degree air
look at those 70 degree people so
arrogant so fooled themselves they're
probably workaholics anyway I'm being
smart I'm cutting back I'm downsizing I
don't want to burn myself out I don't
have more balance in my life now before
you know it they're 62 they only at 58
now by the way when you add when they
add when they ask if th do they Hara
hang around with 70 degree people no
they hang around with 50 degree people
so they feel better about themselves on
a regular basis why do you think people
watch we are the TV
you know what I thought my life is a
mess
look at these people on TV instantly if
you better buy yourself now but you're
at tax obviously you're not like that
you're an overachiever yes an
overachiever so when H when it's
supposed to be a 70 degrees
yes 65 what do you do you do something
about it yes you don't settle you try it
you try something else it doesn't work
you try something else it doesn't work
you try something else
it doesn't work you don't settle you
don't give up and you don't give in
if you hit a wall you go around it you
go over it you go under it whatever it
takes you do it and do you stop at 70
degrees no you keep going until you hit
80 85 90 91 92 93 99 degree and your
brain goes hey hey hey what do you think
you're doing up here you're not a nerdy
degree who do you think you are get back
to where you were and suddenly you
realize you're outside of your comfort
zone and then the heater stopped and you
lose your drive and you begin to
self-sabotage yourself and you stop
doing what got you there in the first
place and you start doing some dumb
things making some dumb decisions until
you get back to exactly where you think
you deserve to be now how many of y'all
know I'm sure none of you have done this
but how many of you have seen other
people sabotage himself
yeah I thought so I thought so you see
the strongest force in human personality
is the need to remain consistent with
how we see ourselves the strongest force
in human personality is the need to
remain consistent with how we see
ourselves so the image that we hold of
ourselves controls our successes and our
failures and also impacts every single
area of our life rule number 10 have a
sense of urgency the average human
lifespan is 75 years 1/3 of your life is
spent sleeping and outer third of your
life is spent on watching TV movies
drinking and partying traveling spending
time with family and friends playing
video games commuting to work buying
groceries paying the bills being stuck
in traffic waiting in line mowing the
lawn cleaning up the house and doing
laundry 25 years left in the first 18
years of your life you are growing up
you are learning to walk eat run and
talk you are totally dependent on
parents and going to school because you
can't really think for yourself call
your own shots or know how to be your
own person that means you have
approximately seven years to make your
dreams come true and if you have a job
you probably spend most of that time
working for someone else instead of
building your own dream life is too
short to waste time on people who don't
lift you up or inspired you life is too
short to be living somebody else's dream
life is too short to wait life is too
short not to take chances life is too
short to wake up with regrets
developed a sense of urgency in the
pursuit of success and freedom you must
step up to live life on your own terms
[Music]
rule number 11 say a lot of yes you need
to say a lot of yes because you never
get more in life by saying no you can
only get more in life by saying yes say
yes to the opportunity say yes meeting
to that new person say yes going to that
new city you want to try a lot of
different things sometimes a lot young
people they ask me well then what should
I focus on what what should I do
what career should I pursue or what's my
passion I say how the do I know you
haven't tried enough things you haven't
fail enough it's like if you only have
tasted certain types of food if you only
taste a hamburger let's say for example
you haven't tried Japanese food
Malaysian food right
Indian food Chinese food how do you know
what's out there how do you know what is
possible how do you know what do you
like you only try one thing you only
stay in one city
you've only hung out with a few people
in your whole life so you want to try
more things it's okay
maybe it's that online business venture
that you want you try ecommerce and it
doesn't work and you try Amazon it
doesn't work and you try to feel the
marketing doesn't work it doesn't matter
what it is but you need to try enough
stuff I started and fail at 13
businesses 13 businesses before having
my first success because I was saying
guest a lot of things most of them
didn't work out and that's okay but I
knew I found out what I don't want to do
if you don't know what you want to do
it's a great place to start
find out what you don't want find out
absolutely what you don't want and what
you don't want to tolerate so first
stage you need to say yes to say yes to
all kinds of opportunities knowing most
of them will fail most of them would be
a waste of time but you'll learn
something from that and that's okay rule
number 12 stand out people don't buy
products and services they buy stories
because when there are so many choices
out in the marketplace on the internet
any any any product that you want
there are hundreds and hundreds of
choices how do you stand out how do you
add emotions to a commodity a pen
what's the difference between a $2.00
pen like this or a an $800 Montblanc
John F Kennedy limited edition exclusive
pen $800 of him it's the same pen it's
the same functions story when he asks
story to it to an item suddenly when you
add the the the John F Kennedy the
president story attached to a brand to a
logo it is ten times more valuable it is
a hundred times more valuable it is
three hundred times more valuable that
particular pen all because a story he
writes the same a $2.00 pen you can
write to that's the difference so think
about what was the story
how can you inject stories into
everything on YouTube rule number 13
show up you ask me all the time where am
i flying to your city where am i going
to fly to you dad loved to attend one of
your seminars when you come to my city
the answers never what if I never come
to your city whatever never fly to your
town then what are you gonna do what if
I don't come three years five years ten
years you're gonna wait ten years it
makes no sense
don't wait nobody's gonna come rescue
you know what it's gonna save you you
got to show up and you got to go to what
ever wherever it takes I remember years
ago when my mentor asked me and say hey
I won't have breakfast I flew to LA just
to have a single breakfast with my
mentor and you're waiting and you're
waiting and what are you waiting for
you're waiting for me to come to your
city you're waiting for the perfect
timing you're waiting for everything is
perfectly lined up you're waiting for
what's convenient the problem is you put
your convenience ahead of your
conviction convenience and conviction
don't live on
same block rule number 14 don't quit I
feel that so many pieces I feel at 13
businesses 13 13 Wow before having what
I quite like Oracle success right so
from 17 to what age did the homicide
within three years so three years 13
businesses in and about losses all
losses or lessons yeah no all losses
haha no it's not as serious yeah yeah it
was and a max of my credit card I lost
on my mom's face savings yeah I heard
that at one point - you're almost over
$100,000 in debt $150,000 $50,000 and
how old are you at that time 20 20 years
old 20 years old and that was just
different loans from your mom relatives
relatives and my brother tests they
wouldn't think might call anymore cuz
yeah yeah it's just I just more of them
everybody that I could did you burn a
lot of bridges at that time - yeah I did
I did but I always promised them that
just let me let give me one more chance
right but let me try harder and they
believed in me but they just thought
they always thought I was kind of odd
when the family said why don't you just
there and just go get a job do something
like what normal people yes safe you're
safe and do something like why do you
have to have these crazy ideas he's
another idea of them yeah and I just
told them hey listen if I were just to
go get a job with my I don't even have a
college degree anything like that I
would be making me a man with minimum
wage listen I'm not $150,000 yeah if I
was making minimum wage it would take me
forever right to pay you off to pay you
back and pay off all this debt and to
provide for my mom so like people always
look at what I did
oh you must be so motivated there it's
not motivation it was desperation right
it was I had no choice rule number 15
don't chase money money is a byproduct
value creation of money is not something
when you try to chase money it doesn't
come to you the more you try to chase
them and I want to make the money I want
to make the money you can see these
people that so desperate they don't make
money you don't make money but if you
are more at ease and you focus on
delivering value yeah money comes
let me think about today how much you
make the effort that you put in versus
they say for many years ago where you
put in a lot of like hot work and you
and I are gonna make money trying to
make that $1,000 how difficult that was
for us now
1,000 bucks is like yeah it's so easy
what changed yeah right yeah what
changed it's a very different mindset
rule number 16 find your why I think
most people they don't get what they
want in life because they don't know
what they want so they lack clarity and
why they lack motivation chances are
they haven't suffered a lot of pain
you can see now we on a private jet
I remember
many years ago when I was struggling in
business couldn't pay the bills
my father had his first stroke and I was
so much in debt and I couldn't even
afford the plane ticket it was in the
hospital he was an emergency and I
couldn't afford even to buy an economy
ticket because I was in Canada and he
was in Hong Kong that incident that
experience just gave me so much pain
when you have enough pain then your
motivation I said to myself I never ever
ever want to live there like that again
whatever it takes I don't want to
experience so helpless that I couldn't
do anything in order to protect my
family in order just have the freedom
the ability to to buy a plane ticket
I need money I need money when if you
want your kids suffer when your wife
needs money when your family needs money
who that's going to help them if it's
not you and you don't get at that point
and what kind of man are we rule number
17 find the right mentors I saw this
book one day on ebay I was just browsing
around to look at some stuff and I saw
the title captivate me it's called your
first hundred million mmm fun what kind
of book is this like that's a pretty
bossy title as a copywriter right that's
a good title right I click on it and I
saw that the price was $400 us for book
I thought it myself
who in the right mind we spent for honey
bucks no I click on the link and he has
the first chapter in the listing I read
I read through the first chapter before
you know it I was the idiot that bought
the book I spent 400 bucks a pocketbook
yeah I read through the whole book they
had such a big impact on me mm-hmm I
guess at the time I was already looking
for the second mentor because I was
already experienced success and Alan
wasn't well and I was looking for
something more and when I saw Dan penny
I can't pick damn right I saw back then
it's like this is the guy wanna learn
from
mm-hmm a cop the castle just straight up
I just called a castle how did you get
the number it's all in the book yeah
right now of course when the first call
to call it Castle you got the gatekeeper
but I went through a lot of like
different things and I went to the
castle seminar and that's how and in
time big there wasn't as popular as
today it was I remember when I went to
the castle is like four or five guys I
was one of them he did it once a year I
think at the time he was maybe in semi
with Hyneman retirement and that's again
he's been my mentor now for more than 10
years keep in mind I was at a time
before the 25 B 25-ish 26 something like
that and then what's making good money
was it give me a half a million whenever
a year after nine a year how a million
years something like that and I would
call Victor and said tell me you know
hey man you know pretty good points on
one years old making half a million but
I was Mia put any guys right right you
feel pretty good about yourself right
twenty some more years oh I'm pretty
smart right and especially after
listening to his voice and make some
changes so I call him a talk so hey you
know so
so he asked me how are you doing oh man
you know this time I'm not doing all
this stuff right so how much money
you're making now you know half half a
million bucks
very good silence so he said so what are
you half a millionaire yeah yeah yeah
that's him
that's it always doesn't matter what I
do every time I talk to him there's
nothing yeah whatever you I I'm doing
whatever compare what he's done is
nothing he always gives you context to
the bigger game they go again rule
number 18 learned from martial arts and
but I find that the mashallah
philosophies have helped me a lot in
business I integrate them I do blue
belief is transferable for sure so like
in martial art I'd why why gravity to
words Bruce Lee's martial art because
it's about simplicity is about
directness mm-hmm same thing in business
I like to be direct I like to go off
using a similar simple model yeah so
it's the same idea that's so I think
that affected me a lot is the way I
think
rule number 19 get used to being
uncomfortable you need to be comfortable
being uncomfortable you need to get used
to being uncomfortable human being we
don't like discomfort you know how
sometimes you sit for too long and then
you're like all right I gotta I gotta
change I gotta change other you are very
very comfortable until you get
uncomfortable sitting for a long time
then you want to adjust right you want
to you want to move around that's
exactly it you have to make yourself
uncomfortable on a consistent basis the
things that you're afraid of to do the
action you're afraid to take the risk
you are afraid to take you guys take it
when you feel uncomfortable you know
what I'm conditioning myself for success
rule number 20 pick the right vehicle
most people they overestimate their
importance in terms of success so I
think they say four they say this take
raising horses for example the the
jockey is important but the horse is
probably more important so I think very
often when something is successful
entrepreneurs like oh because I'm so
good
rather I I mean I conquered a problem I
made it happen
and all this stuff now as I'm more
mature I think finding the right
opportunity is probably way it's like
ten times more important so the vehicle
the vehicle and at time I picked the
right vehicle because I was remember the
13 businesses mr. wrong vehicle I was
the wrong person but this time that's
why I don't believe the whole thing all
you got to be at the right place at
right time you have to be the right
person in the right place at the right
time I was the right person I had the
skill I was on line I had to I have the
suppliers right I was making money to
all this stuff
now my skills I have a platform to
exercise my talents and skills and money
was coming in the how come it took me so
much effort before to make $1,000 right
and now like it just make that yeah you
couldn't even stop the money it's like I
couldn't stop what changed yeah has I
picked the right vehicle do you remember
that first time where you made an amount
of money that even blew your mind like
oh [ __ ] this is possible I do you number
a cheque that sticks out no it's not
cheque is all this money coming in
mm-hmm and I wasn't thinking about it I
was getting there just spending money
and I was 27 yeah 27 years old I look at
my bank account mm-hmm got a million
dollars in cash mm-hmm okay
not net worth cash liquid liquid like
that's a lot of money right that's what
I thought this is all money right and
this is this is from copywriting in
sales and affiliates or how evolved all
internet at the time I had multiple
internet businesses this is one thing
too or not renumber 21 sacrifice the
first five years of my business career
when I was getting started the first
five years I didn't take a single day
off I was working 12 to 14 hours a day
seven days a week for the first five
years while all my friends they were out
there drinking drinking and having
parties and chasing girls I was working
I sacrifice and me a lot of sacrifices I
believe if you don't sacrifice for your
dream then your dream become
your sacrifice so I made a decision I
pay the price
early on I spent a few years of my life
working on myself working on my business
doing the things that most people are
too lazy to do not willing to do so I
could have what most people cannot have
rule number 22 bring results number 2
poor people get paid based on time rich
people get paid based on results let's
say you're working on McDonald's you may
be the best floor cleaner on the planet
ever but what value do you bring to
McDonald rich people we get paid based
on result not time invested let's say
we're working on a product we spent a
year creating perfecting the product we
bring it to the marketplace and it sucks
it bombs it doesn't make us a dime the
world doesn't give up we don't make
money nobody cares how much time blood
sweat and tears were put into creating a
product and bring it to the marketplace
how much risk that we take they don't
care what they care is a result that's
why the highest pay athlete in the world
they don't get paid by how many hours
they practice how many times they invest
it no it is how much they perform they
get paid based on performance rule
number 23 change your identity it's very
difficult to to create any kind of
change if you hold on to your identity
that's right the example I to give it's
like people who want to like quit
smoking right if like oh if my dentists
is I'm a smoker yeah it's always a
struggle yeah right it's always well I
want to have that powerful have that
cigarette yeah versus someone who's not
a smoker yeah
then it's there's no temptation in fact
like for guys that we don't smoke we can
stand even feel sorry I can't smell yeah
right we do now thinking about oh I
can't wait to have a cigarette yeah so
until unless they change identities
right I always talk about it I was a
millionaire in my mind that's right way
before I had the money in my bank
account
yeah the way even when I had no money I
never worried about the gas prices or
how much
that's cause like those things don't
enter my mind yeah it just took many
years for the reality to catch up rule
number 24 think if you were to ask me
take away everything I have take away
all the tools that I have in business in
sales in marketing everything I have but
you can leave me with one thing with
what would I pick without hesitation I
will tell you is thinking time the
ability to think because business is an
intellectual sport creating wealth is an
intellectual sport becoming successful
in - it's an intellectual sport not
necessary smart you are but the ability
to think what is going on thinking time
most people don't think enough Henry
Ford said it best thinking is the
hardest work there is that's why so few
of you were engaged in it what I mean by
thinking does that mean you locked
yourself in a room and just sit there
and let whatever thoughts that come to
mind and that's thinking no let me teach
you how to think this is probably to the
right person watching this it is the
most valuable skill the most valuable
lesson that I could teach you this is
literally the one thing that has made me
who I am today
the one thing that created Dan Locke one
thing and that's thinking time here's
how it works then what you think is very
simple you get yourself in a quiet
environment maybe you turn on some music
doesn't really matter
thinking is nothing more than asking
yourself profound and deep questions
that's what thinking is how's it again
thinking there's nothing more than
asking yourself deep and profound
questions when I said to even profile it
means asking those questions that takes
a little time you need to think about it
not a very service level questions let
me give you an example if you ask
yourself the question why can I make
more money that kind of quality of a
question leads to poor answers horrible
answers because think about it
you ask your mind well why can I make
more money what comes to mind what cause
you suck because you no good because
you're not worthy because nobody likes
you because nobody wants to buy your
stuff
nobody wants to do business with you or
maybe you don't have enough experience
you don't have a track record you don't
have enough resources you don't know the
right people all this how does that help
you in any way a better question to ask
maybe perhaps is well how can I make
more money but then that's also a very
basic question basic question but if you
spend the time and you actually think
about and sit down and dissect and you
take the time to craft a very profound
questions so you could say how can I
make more money how can you make that
better how can you make that question
better okay how about instead of being
so vague and so general instead of how
can I make more money how can I make
more sales there's a difference if you
run a business how that make more sales
okay
how about let's make it even better how
can I make more cells without getting
any new customers that's interesting you
see how now you're thinking from a
different perspective how about this let
me give it one more layer how can i en't
more say how can I make more sales
without adding any new customers and
we're down adding any new expense hmm
now I see how does a high quality
question what you do is thinking time
you get you get put yourself in my space
you write that questions at the top how
can I make more sales
without adding any new customers without
adding any expense new expense and now
you sit down and you go a pen a piece of
paper and you answer that you take your
time oh well I could sell more to my
existing customers interesting I can
maybe increase my price so I can make
more money interesting maybe I could
also do a joint venture with someone
where only pay them on a performance
basis so if they bring more sales then I
pay them it doesn't add any more expense
to what I do that's interesting maybe
maybe I could also instead of selling
something one time I can sell it and
it's some kind of continuity there so my
customer I pay me on it ongoing basis
maybe some kind of membership that's
interesting
you see that's thinking
it's not just how can I make more money
see it's a very low level when you take
the time to think that's how you grow
that's actually how you actually think
and grow rich this is very deep
so ponder on there but if you get this
there's one thing this one skill this is
what makes you successful that's the
difference between the poor and the rich
rule number 25 continuously learn number
5 poor people they know it all
rich people continuously to learn you
see poor people are always very
opinionated they always want to tell the
world about the opinions about politics
about sports about the society about the
government about every single thing
that's around them versus being humble
willing to learn rich people were always
learning we're asking questions we are
listening we are reading books
continuous learning versus saying that I
have a god on are painting above
everything you know why they're always
an opinion poor people because the only
way to get any bit attention no
different I can see people they're
watching my video watching my sales
video closing video and I just look at
that and laugh and they common Oh Dan
you shouldn't close this way you should
close that way just say this when was
the last time you enclose something show
me when is the last time you close
something for $500 $1,000 $2,000 $5,000
$10,000 $100,000 what have you done so
you're painting doesn't count remember
your income can only go to the extent
that you do your wealth can only grow as
fast as with you
rule number 26 set your goals properly I
like to think of okay this is the ideal
lifestyle that I want and I talk about
any of your money right
what's that have your money targets and
what's how much would that cost you not
Ref not how much you roughly maybe know
let's calculate that yeah and what I
realize is after all these years talked
to so many people whatever the idea that
they have they say I want to be able to
travel I want to be able to have to
drive this particular car or have this
particular house or this kind of
lifestyle when they actually break it
down yeah doesn't cost them as much as
they think they thought oh the Osmos
money a million dollars I need ten
million dollars only there's throwing it
random numbers in yeah because they said
number that's totally unrealistic we're
just Oh actually no I could accomplish
all I want to accomplish with maybe
$300,000 a year
yeah well that's a very different goal
than thirty million dollars a year right
rule number 27 have an action mentality
number seven poor people they have
lottery mentality and rich people we
have action mentality you see most
people they believe the only way to get
rich it's buying a lottery ticket even
though they know that the chance of
winning is slim to none but they buy
their fantasy hopefully if I win I'm
gonna buy their house I'm gonna quit
that job I'm gonna take that vacation no
rich people have an action mentality we
believe if it's going to be it is up to
me I'm gonna make it happen I'm gonna
make myself successful
rule number 28 identify trends if you
want to retire early and retire young
one of the most important things that
you have to know is noticing and
identifying trends at a time I went onto
the internet I saw this trend on the
Internet
we're talking about back then remember
Netscape dial-up modem
I'm talking about overture for
pay-per-click you know good old days you
watching this young young guys you may
or may not even know this but I'm
talking about Yahoo for search engines
okay
Facebook and then later on Google but
I'm talking about that so when I got
started back then early and I noticed a
trend on internet and I was importing
collectibles from Hong Kong Bruce Lee
collectibles actually and I was flipping
them on eBay I was doing affiliate
marketing I was doing digital marketing
online or selling digital products
before PDF before all these things were
even popular software all these things
and that's how my first bucket of money
then I took that money and I saw some of
those of this assistance I cash out and
I took that money and invest in real
estate
then my investments are able to support
my lifestyle and that's how I retire at
the age of 27
rule number 29 believe in yourself when
I was in my 20s so at the first
mastermind group mastermind group I
joined which is awesome it's by
organized by my mentor Alan so he had
this marketing master Michael I was in
my 20s I was the youngest guy I'm not
supposed to get in because I'm a minty
so he kind of put me in there yeah kind
of us almost my sake it's just a
tag-along right yeah and I remember
sitting around with all these
millionaires yeah all these guys they
were successful I was making like like I
don't know nothing makes it nothing
like maybe maybe 80,000 90,000 a year
something like that I was looking at
these guys
you know the biggest thing thing I got
out of it not to put them down they're
not that smart
yeah there was it do you think they're
not that smart
yeah like the whatever they're talking
about I get and it's not like rocket
science
yeah dad that's right believe it's like
hey maybe I guess it maybe I could do
that - yeah that's all you need
maybe I could do that - yeah that's a
starting point that's the spark right
that's planting the seed then you can go
from there
okay now what are they to you what
resources do I then do I need would I
have to be you know to do to become that
person yes
rule number 30 do martial arts
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
rule number 31 push yourself I believe
the number one habit you need to devolve
to be successful it's on a consistent if
not a daily basis do things that make
you feel uncomfortable it is that simple
because you look at what holds most
people back what holds you back is fear
fear of the unknown fear of failure fear
of rejection fear of success all these
things is all outside their comfort zone
human being because we're creature of
habits we tend to operate day to day and
do the same thing again and again and
again but if you have a habit you make a
habit that you do things on a consistent
basis that you don't usually do it makes
you scare it scare stuff out of you it
makes you stretch your comfort zone
that's how you gradually expand it and
get more of what you want maybe is going
to the event that you've never been to
maybe is meeting their successful people
that in that intimidates you maybe is
reading a book that you have no interest
reading in maybe it's driving a
different path that you usually call
home this way hey you know what I'm
gonna drive a different path and see
something a little bit different right
maybe it's watching a video that you
don't usually watch may be interested
certain topics maybe you're watching a
youtube video just on prank but
something you want something that is on
inspiration and motivational that's
practical that's business-related and
that changes the way that you think
about stuff it started with that one
thing that one video and if you do that
not one time not two times not three
times but hundreds and hundreds of times
on a consistent basis I believe that is
the habit not just to be successful but
to stay successful when you're
constantly pushing yourself outside of
the comfort zone guess what you will
learn
you will take new action you acquired
new knowledge you will meet new people
and that will lead to new opportunities
you might develop a new skill right you
might start a new business all these
things that you do is nothing more than
doing things that scares the [ __ ] out of
you
on a consistent basis instead of
avoiding the fear you are facing the
fear and you are pushing and pushing and
pushing a limit that is the number one
thing that you need I strongly believe
to be successful so develop the habited
a do something that you don't usually do
do something that scares you do
something that makes you uncomfortable
rule number 32 eliminate distractions
key number two you want to eliminate
distraction and interruptions in your
life so how can you be productive in any
given time during the day if you're
interrupted all the time I think even
entrepreneur CEOs they have this like
open door policy where hey you know what
my door is open come talk to me anytime
I think it was one of the dumbest ideas
because it means you get interrupted
many many many times every single day
and every time you get interrupted it
takes you so the mental bandwidth to
stay and get back on track so when I am
working and pluck the phone I create an
environment that people cannot reach to
me if I want to check messages I want to
check email I want to get back to my
team that's fine but if I am what I call
the bat-cave moment I unplug all
communication my cell phone my none zero
it's all my thinking time my planning
time my strategy time that's it so when
they cannot find you they cannot
interrupt you when they cannot find you
they cannot distract you so communicate
with your team and to be around you and
say hey I'm working on my business I'm
building something here I'm working with
some very very important tasks I need to
get those done please give me the space
during that time don't bother me zooming
in the office when I'm working sometimes
from home when I close the door then
Jenny knows right that she doesn't come
in and interrupt me right my wife knows
that no that's
dents working time he needs to stay
focus so put yourself an environment
that you cannot be distracted that's key
number two rule number 33 take
responsibility number three poor people
they blame others for their misfortunes
rich people we take responsibility for
our own failures you see for poor people
is always somebody else's fault it's the
economy is the government it's my boss
it's my job it's my city it's my
neighbor it's my friends it's always
somebody else it's never their own fault
rich people we take responsibility if
your life stinks is your fault we take
responsibility for all action when you
take responsibility
what happens is you gain power the power
to change the power to do something
different remember lame people blame
people rule number 34 have energy you
don't have enough energy how do you
expect to accomplish anything
significant accomplish your goals when
you don't have enough energy you notice
the society puts down and look down on
people they have high energy imagine
you're going to school you're going to
work you're going back to your office
you're going back to your business and
suddenly you're so energetic and you
have your all hyped up what would people
say to you what's wrong with you dude
like calm them down relax why are you so
excited
but somehow you have low energy hey man
that's okay
you know what fine stands stands for
freaked out in debt not making enough
money emotionally stressed out fi nd
that's what it stands for I mind a is
fine that's what fine words but somehow
you've high energy it is wrong you won't
have energy you got to move laughing my
March off back on if you watch my video
you follow my work you know move jumping
jack push-up walk yoga whatever the it
takes move your body when you move you
have more energy when you sit there all
day for hours how the hell can you have
energy movement creates energy so if
you're sitting there for a long day get
up stand up walk around do something I
know jumping up and down water it is do
something rule number 35 serve a need
maybe you're thinking well I need to do
something I'm passionate about
well it's nice that you're passionate
about something but that is not enough
because the marketplace doesn't care
what you're passionate about the
marketplace is very very selfish they
care what you can do for them so in
order to make a million dollars he's my
first tip for you instead of chasing
money chasing money doesn't get you
money money doesn't go to the people who
were desperately needed or definitely
wanted money goes to people who can add
value to market place it goes to the
people who knows how to multiply it so
instead of chasing money he's what I
want you to do chase needs that's right
you know to make a million dollars you
need to serve a need in the marketplace
or you to solve a problem in the
marketplace or customers for the
consumer for people you've got to put
people first so to make a million
dollars the archery only two paths
either it's volume or transaction size
volume and transaction size now what do
I mean by that so if you sell something
in terms of volume you startled me for a
dollar you serve
a million people guess what you got your
million bucks I would challenge to think
about this
anyone that's making millions of dollars
either they are serving a huge amount of
people meaning they are selling or
serving or impacting millions or you
look at Apple guess what billions and
billions of dollars they serve and
billions and billions of people look at
Facebook look at Google billions and
billions of dollars billions and
billions of users so if it's not volume
then its transaction size meaning you
sell something for millions of dollars
let's say a real estate developer
selling a unit for millions and billions
of dollars well you sell one unit you
make millions of dollars it's one of
those two or something in between sell
something for and $20,000 you sell a few
hundred of those you get your million
bucks it's that simple
doesn't matter what business model you
use it's either you play the volume game
which them you want to scale you want to
serve and impact millions or you're
playing the transaction size game where
you sell something at a high ticket
which is what I teach and you work with
fewer clients serve a smaller group of
people but in a higher level and a high
quality you can also get your millions
of dollars see you're not gonna get your
millions of dollars just hoping the oh I
want I want a millions of dollars on it
with my million bucks nobody cares you
can sit at home you can play in for a
computer you can meditate whatever you
do you're not gonna get that million
dollars fall on your left that's not how
the marketplace works but if you can
find a way to serve a need in the
marketplace and to solve people's
problems
either through a huge amount of volume
impacting millions or in a very profound
way such as real estate or insurance or
whatever it is or automobile it doesn't
matter more than what it is
but you gotta sell something nothing
happens unless a cell it's made nothing
happens in life and in business until
you make a cell and that's how it works
rule number 36 change your mindset
number six poor people believe that
money is the root of all evil rich
people we
if that poverty is the root of all evil
you've heard of the saying money is the
root of all evil no lack of money is the
root of all evil I want you to look at
the poorest neighborhoods I would just
think about those areas crime drug
problems all kinds of issues you see in
the history of mankind no banks been
wronged by someone pulling up in a
rosewood it is the survival is the lack
of money that's causing the issue money
self it's neutral
money's like a tool you can use it for
good or you can use it for evil it is
all up to you
rule number 37 learn to execute I've got
so many people come to me and they say
to me then I've got this great idea for
this business would you like to invest
in my company or in my business as a
health no I said no and they thought the
idea is everything and it's very funny
because they are so protective of their
little idea oh yeah but if I tell you
the idea and it is just signing an NDA
non-disclosure agreement because I don't
want to tell you idea yet it's stupid
you have to understand ideas are not
worth a lot in business execution is
everything execution is everything you
see to create any substantial amount of
wealth you need what you need the right
team at the right time to execute the
right idea in the right industry the
idea that you have without the right
team without the right time without the
right industry is not gonna work
rule number 38 capture more market share
I want you to think about the top very
top of the the pyramid the top 3% at any
given time only 3% of the market place
who you're selling to is interested and
ready to buy what you have to offer only
top 3% and most salespeople
entrepreneurs they are always only
talking to the top 3% anything that's
not within a 2/3 percent they're not
ready to buy right now they just ignore
them the problem is you are completely
ignoring
the other 97% now besides the 3% let's
talk about the 7% they are your ideal
customers and clients they are capable
of buying they are open and interested
they just maybe need you to answer some
of the questions they're kind of on the
fence right the 7% and some business
owners they do try to communicate and
market and talk to that 7% but let's
talk about below that the other 30% so
you have the top 10% the 30% below it
this is the ones that warm market these
people that they like you know I'm kind
of interested I could be convinced I
could be persuaded right I might have a
knee maybe maybe maybe not right now but
they could be persuade if you do the
right thing so that's the 30% and then
below that you have the other 30% which
they don't even think they are
interested they're not even thinking
about it they just don't know they don't
even know why they need what you have to
offer and then you have the bottom 30%
which is there's no way in hell they're
gonna buy from you
this is the people it doesn't matter
what you do they don't like you they
don't trust you they don't need what you
sell like if you're selling a stick
these are the vegeterian right they
don't want to buy what yourself so I
want you to think about in your
marketing message the way that you do
your marketing who are you talking to if
you're only talking to the top 3% which
is what most people do you are leaving a
big chunk of the market place you're not
talking to them you're only talking to
the very very top data ready to buy
right now which is nice but you under
you have to understand that's a very
very small percentage of the marketplace
so what could you do to get and to
capture more market share out of this
equation I don't want to talk to only
the the top 3% or even a top 10% I want
to talk to all 70% rule number 39 do
martial arts like character my
personality a lot of that came from
martial art is no doubt in my mind as a
businessman as an entrepreneur as a
husband a lot of philosophies I
from martial art I learned a lot from
Bruce Lee obviously you learn to focus
you learn self-discipline you learn
respect
because we learn how to learn how to how
to bow right you learn to be patient you
learn to know that you need to put an
effort you need to put on time to
develop a skill set and also you learn
to be aware of your own flaw you learn
to eliminate your own defect that's what
Marat is about every step of the way you
learn how to eliminate your own defect
you learned hey you know what I'm
punching this way it's not enough power
it's not enough speed my timing is not
good or whatever it might be but you
learn to develop you learn to hone your
skill set and that's through that
process you learn you learn about
yourself as itself it's a
self-actualization process rule number
40
be yourself not hostile towards people
have negative comments or dislike me
frankly I don't give up I really do not
give up because people first of all they
dislike the keyboard warriors they've
probably at home that's why you're poor
sometimes you even you guys ask me a
question god dammit where it's so I have
over it's not six seven hundred videos
on YouTube no Dan can ask you a question
about this it's on YouTube already but
you can't even search it it's - can't
even type in the word to search that
video to watch the click they watch the
video all dan is - huh can you organize
it okay fine all guys have playlists for
you I can't find a playlist even that's
too difficult there is even a problem
and you say you want to be successful
give me a break
you came very quick enough thing how
could you not have confidence when
you're so good at what you do that's a
problem with young people you're not
good at anything oh I'm so good no tell
me the truth
you're not good at anything no substance
you have no foundation
rule number 41 have an entrepreneurial
mindset
save yourself before you try to save the
world the best way to help the poor is
not to become one of them it is your
duty it is your obligation it is your
responsibility to maximize your profits
as an entrepreneur think of
let me give an analogy it's like if you
want to give blood how many begged blood
you can give before you pass out and die
[Music]
that's that's linear thinking that's an
employee mentality you want to give
blood bill hospital
that's entrepreneurial mindset that's
entrepreneurial mindset now some people
may say but then money is not that
important oh man you know money doesn't
buy a happiness I'll talk to my wife
you don't think money
yeah if you talked to her she would say
Eevee though you'll think money can buy
happiness you don't know where to shop
okay and money here's the thing
money is not supposed to buy you
happiness money is supposed to give you
two things how many things two things
first money gives you comfort makes your
life a little bit easier and second
thing is money allows you to do to
extend the goods that you do beyond your
physical presence to only two things
when people want to hear
oh yeah money is not that important
money buy something buy happiness
very often oh it's a stupid statement
first of all but second thing is usually
it's a defensive statement it's usually
people would say that you either don't
you don't have any oh they don't they
don't know how to get some guarantee so
from now on you can be a psychic you
hear people our money is not the
important money doesn't buy happiness oh
my goodness let me think let me think
you're broke and it would be like how do
you know rule number 42 love what you do
what would you do non-stop even you
never got paid for it no is not playing
video games that's not what I'm talking
about what are some the skills some
value some expertise you can offer to
help people even you never got paid for
it you know if you remember there was a
scene in The Dark Knight and the Joker
said well if you even good at something
never do it for free
he was talking about the gang side the
Mafia try to kill Batman I believe
that's true if you're good with
something you're good at something never
do it for free now you may have heard of
the saying people say well I love this
so much I would do it for free I think
it is a broke person's mentality it's a
very 97 percent mentality here's my
belief and you don't have to buy my
belief but he's my belief I believe in
life you should find something and you
would say to yourself you know what I
love this so much
it is the only thing I
for money when you can find that when
when you can identify your brilliance
when you can find something that you
truly enjoy doing then your work and
your life becomes one it's not so much I
go to work and I finished work and I go
home then
don't talk to me about work it's no it's
working life integration you love what
you do life it's work and work it's life
then guess what you never have to work
another day of your life because work
doesn't feel like work anymore
rule number 43 develop high income
skills do of Brooke
why are you Brooke have you ever asked
yourself that question and how do you
never be broke again I was broke when I
was a teenager when it came to Canada
with nothing no money I was in debt a
hundred and fifty thousand dollars in
debt I was so frustrated I tried so many
different things
I started and fail at thirteen
businesses thirteen not three not ten
thirteen businesses Oh disaster not only
did I make money from the businesses I
was in debt lots all my mom's money
borrow from friends and family and I
didn't know why I wanted to succeed so
bad but I just couldn't make it work
until one thing until I had an epiphany
what is that PIFAN II you don't have a
money problem you have a skill problem
if you try to solve your money problem
with just money your problem doesn't get
solved money problem is not solved by
money money problem is solved by your
intelligence and your skill set your
mindset and your skill set now what am I
talking about your skill set I want you
to think about some of the highest pay
people in the society they say doctor
they say attorney let's say lawyer let's
say accountant engineer who is making a
decent high income what do they have
they have specialized skill sets that me
you may not have see the people with low
income skills in society in our society
low income jobs
chances are desk used now that doesn't
mean they don't work hard it doesn't
mean they don't hustle
it doesn't mean they'll work long hours
but the skills that they have that they
offer to the marketplace to society
people companies they are not willing to
pay big money for I call them low income
skills that's the problem you try to
make big money with low income skills
you need to develop your high income
skills in order to make more money so if
you're struggling in life you're
struggling in business I can guarantee
you the biggest issue how I've overcome
how I was struggling how overcome not
want to be broke again it's I learned to
close
I learned to communicate ideas thought
concepts when you learn to close you'll
never be broke again because in business
nothing happens until something is sold
in life nothing happens until something
is sold you're single you're not good
closer you can't cause you're not
getting our people to do what you want
they're not following your leadership
you can't close you're not getting sales
because you're lousy closer you can't
close when you can close you can move
you can influence you can persuade
people everything that you want in life
guess what other people already have
them I don't care what is it you want
resources money capital influence
relationships whatever it is that you
want you got to close someone else to
give it to you so if you're struggling
financially it means you're a lousy
closer it is that simple what that's the
downside upside is this once you know
how to close you will know how to create
income on demand you will know how to
make money you have the ability to make
money anytime you want that's the power
of closing that's how you never go broke
again rule number 44 do whatever it
takes
business is tough I fail at 13
businesses before having my first
success so my question is how bad do you
want it see statistics 96% of companies
go out of business fail they all fail
within the first 10 years it means that
only 4 out of 100 companies make it in
10 years so you look at an audience of a
thousand people in 10 years time only 40
of you would be still here so business a
game of business is not for the weak the
game of business is not for the wannabe
the game of business is for the
ambitious the game of business is for
the committed the game of business is
for the people who do whatever the it
takes to succeed
rule number 45 don't be controlled by
media the mainstream media and
advertisers they want you to consume why
do they want you to consume it so that
they could better control you starting
at a young age you were taught to spend
money that you don't have to buy things
you don't need to impress people you
don't even like in your life you want to
buy that toys for your kids put down
their credit card you want take that
vacation put it on that credit card hey
you want to buy that Neil cotton you
cannot afford that's okay get a second
credit card borrow from your mortgage
it's perfectly normal to have some debt
do you have a lot of debt and that's the
problem that we have in the world
especially in North America that's why
families they are heavily in debt and
when you are in debt you are controlled
by the media and you're controlled by
the financial institutions and your
control by the banks remember that rule
number 46 have a strong why I believe
most entrepreneurs fail because they
start the business with the wrong reason
and intent every single time I speak to
a group of want to be entrepreneurs or
entrepreneurs and I ask them the
question how many of you want to start
your own business and a majority of the
hands would go up maybe 50 60 80 percent
then I will ask them the next question
why and usually I hear one of these
three things I want more money I want to
make more money or I want more freedom
or the most comment on it I one more one
time now if you want to start your own
business or you have the aspiration to
start your own business because you want
more time
comment below now the problem with this
is a myth Michael Gerber talks about the
book email he said most entrepreneurs
they're actually not entrepreneurs they
are what we call employees suffering
from an entrepreneurial seizure and
that's the e-myth entrepreneur myth
meaning that one day they did something
the boss yell at them or they feel like
they have a good idea and they say you
know what
this I'm gonna start my own thing they
are employee with employee mentality and
skill set but they suffering from an
entrepreneurial seizure-like who know I
want to do this I'm gonna be my own
thing I'm gonna fire my boss and quit my
job and do my own thing right if you
want to start a business because you
want more time let me tell you this
starting a business because you've won
more time is as if you're saying I want
to have more time and have a baby I want
have a baby and I have more time it's
not gonna happen
so you have to start with the right
intent start with the right motivation
and knowing that it's going to take some
time is you're not gonna get more time
in the first two three five maybe even
ten years and you're okay with that can
you endure that frustration the pain
that sacrifice if not then don't be
entrepreneur just go get a job do
something else this is not your path
there are other ways to make money you
don't have to be an entrepreneur to make
money don't be sold on the idea that yes
I need to be entrepreneur in order to be
wealthy not necessary it's not necessary
there are other ways to make money
rule number 47 serve a lot of people see
in my book a few money
I talk about freedom see freedom is not
the ability do not be ability whatever
you want it's not freedom is having the
luxury of not having to do something
when you don't want to so you don't need
to take crap from nobody that's freedom
because it makes no sense to me when you
work hard and you do your best and
students have to struggle to make ends
meet
I believe that entrepreneurs who do a
good job deliver value to the
marketplace deserve to be well paid let
me ask you a question how many believe
you deserve to be well paid hell yeah
you see money earned write this down
money earn it's a byproduct of value
creation money earned it's a byproduct
value creation the more money you make
the more value you deliver the more
people it just simply means that the
more value deliver to more people more
impact the more money you're gonna make
I make a lot of money because I serve a
lot of people it's very very simple
there are some other people like you
know of Wall Street guys and this and
that they do it some other ways but most
successful people they're successful
because they serve a lot of people rule
number 48 get clarity when it comes to
reading I read a book sometimes if I'm
looking for any book that I read I have
a simple question I want to get through
what are the three ideas that I can get
from a book that can implement right now
just three not 10 not 20 not 100 three
ideas if I could get those three ideas
from the first three chapters I'll
highlight those I will take those and
I'll put the book away one of the most
powerful tool when the ball most
powerful mindset you need to have in
life on business is clarity and clarity
is power
clarity is power and what is power the
power is the ability to take action so
if the more you read the more confused
that you get it gives you less clarity
it means it takes away from your power
if more reading gives you more clarity
and gives you more ability to act that's
good that's powerful right that's that's
on the right track so there's a big
difference between information and
knowledge and knowledge to wisdom let me
explain this would gives you a lot of
clarity information is just facts data
numbers figures theories principles
that's just information there's a lot of
information on the Internet there's a
lot of information on YouTube there's a
lot of information on Google there's a
lot of information but information
itself does not help you it does not
make you richer it does not does not
make you happier it does not make you
healthier it does not make you smarter
information is just information it's
like you go to school right you're
reading you're going to class you you're
your textbook there's a lot of
information in the textbook right that's
the first stage once you gather enough
information now you're accumulating what
I call knowledge so you get a lot of
information and you now learn about the
distinctions now you take that
information you apply it or may take
that information and you take a test
that's knowledge after the test you know
after the exam in school oh that works
so oh no that's what's the wrong answer
or I didn't pass the the the exam or
here they're the mistakes that I got
wrong well
you're learning from it right that's
accumulating your knowledge so a lot of
people they read books to acquire
information you want to be there quite
information and you wonder how come I'm
watching a lot of videos I'm learning
but my life is do the same because you
haven't convert information to know
and from knowledge into experience now
how to convert knowledge into experience
so now you get you acquire some
knowledge you've got to implement and
the only way you get experience and you
up a lot right
you make the mistakes you see this stuff
works right now you're getting
experience you're seeing a pattern of
things going goes back to the the school
example now you take enough exams
remember the class you take from like
grade 9 10 11 12 right now you're taking
of exams studying the same subject for
many years in a row now you see a
pattern okay
I'm accumulating more things I'm getting
more experience of what works and what
doesn't
now experience that's much more valuable
it's more valuable in knowledge and
knowledge is more available information
so books itself is just information
information does not change your life
information doesn't change your life you
got to convert it by gathering a filter
into knowledge from knowledge now you
implement now you get to the next step
which is experience then from experience
from now you you have done it long
enough a long period of time now is
evolved into your wisdom a lot of people
are smart but they're not wise wisdom is
something completely different okay
wisdom is knowing what not to do wisdom
is knowing when you don't have to do
something so let's say enough experience
you know what this is how I'm going to
make this work these are 20 things that
I could do my experience tells me these
are the 20 things I could do to make me
successful wisdom is knowing okay 19
leads is motion just do this one that is
the difference
rule number 49 understand the
marketplace so I always say the amount
of money that you make is in direct
proportion to how how deep you
understand your marketplace is pain
the amount of money you make is in
direct proportion of how well how deep
you go how much you understand your
marketplace is pain so you have to
understand what it is one or the order
what are the things that people have and
how can you help them relieve some of
that pain and rule number 50 the last
for me for a very special bonus rule is
invest in relationships with mentors so
when looking for a mentor yes
let's say we take you out of the picture
yeah all right
how do you know if they are in in this
just to to be a guru and sell you [ __ ]
or if they're actually are able to help
you you don't you don't it's like how do
you know is you just say any single
people in the room okay couple of people
how do you know when go on a date that
that's gonna be the one you just don't
know but you will find out pretty
quickly you will find out pretty quickly
you look at this stuff you connect with
them are they being helpful are they
actually helping you right and you can
see well you know yeah it is helpful
then you know you keep you continued
relationship the good thing about this
simulation ship versus like a marriage
it doesn't work you can you can stop
anytime you can stop calling them you
can stop asking them questions so I
think it's not being afraid just to ask
and say like just today is interesting
today I just finished an interview with
a gentleman called cocktail for my
podcast just before I came here
and he is very successful zero
entrepreneur company doing about fifty
sixty million dollars a year raised up a
hundred million dollars and at the end
of the interview I said hey no Dale can
I can I can I ask you some stuff can I
hire you can I can you be my mentor he
said well you know Dan and I'm quite
busy but even you need help yes she'll
be a mentor I just asked I said I'm more
than happy to pay you
I pay my mentors don't feel like it's
not so much that your mentor doesn't
need your money
you understand that but paying them it's
it's some skin in the game and they know
you're serious it's just like I have
probably now a 12 a dozen entrepreneurs
they pay me a thousand bucks a month for
an hour of my time every month thousand
bucks an hour you know it's not only the
money but if they pay that one thousand
bucks I know that they're serious and
they didn't going to implement what I
teach them that's that's fine that's
totally fine so I do that little bit you
know in my spare time but that's what I
mean don't be afraid it you know invest
in your mentor you know I buy my mentor
gifts I just like my mentor my Dan Pena
seventh birthday SMI nice gift
how can you expect your mentor to invest
in a relationship when you don't even
spend a time and effort in the
relationship it makes no sense you want
them to help you you want them to help
you grow you want them to help you
succeed but what have you done for them
what have you shown nothing they don't
need anything from you and I'm always
very humble very grateful moment mentors
I always thank them I appreciate what
they have done because it is it is
because of what they have helped me to
do so that's what I would say don't be
afraid you know you will know but all
you can do is ask and then do it
now I've got a really special bonus clip
with Dan on how to find your drive that
I think you're gonna really enjoy but
before that it's time for the
three-point landing questions time to
move from just watching another video
and actually take action in your life or
business and if you're feeling bold
leave your answers in the comments below
here we go
question number one how will you invest
in a relationship with a potential
mentor number two what is your strong
why and number three what mindset change
do you need to make
while I emigrated to Canada when I was
14 years old right and then my mom and
dad got divorced when I was 16 years old
and shortly after that my dad actually
went bankrupt in Hong Kong so at the
time my mom and I were living in a
one-bedroom apartment that we were
renting in Surrey near the King George
sketching station and my mom would in
say in the bedroom and I would sleep on
the floor or in the living room and at a
time because then my my well after my
dad went bankrupt he at first he was
setting uh sleeping allowance money but
enough of what's because he had no money
anymore
so he couldn't send us money anymore and
that's when I learned that cuz I was the
only child in my family that I had to
learn to be self-reliant that even
sometimes you're you can't even rely on
your dad to provide for you and so
because of that experience I started my
first business when I was very very
young like in high school that I was
always very driven to be successful
funny thing is I mean the whole money
thing actually does not interest me that
much it's just because seeing my mom
seeing her suffer that I don't know like
for most people what drives them some
people is freedom some people it's
providing for family or some people they
want a nice car whatever it is but to me
is it's okay to let myself down it's not
okay to let my family down that was my
thing where I have to to be successful
to to protect the people I love hi this
is Dan Locke if you're a fan of Evans
work if you want to know exactly how the
model my success I want to invite you to
join me for a special online training
all you have to do is click on a link
below you can join me for absolutely no
charge so click a link below and I will
see you in class
if you want more Dane Locke check out
the six pieces of life-changing advice
video from Dan Locke that we made the
link is right there next to me I think
you'll enjoy it continue to believe and
I'll see you there
clarity is power and
is power the power is the ability to
take action